Uh, we actually had a pretty rich physical life in my opinion.
>> Did this guy just say we a lot we a lot? Yo, we all
the time. This is the most depressing stream I've ever seen in
my life. I asked my child, "How do you rate your life on a scale
of 1 to 10?" Bro, what the [__] are you saying on
your live stream right now? I He's He's an open book right now
and it's so bad. I I want him to stop talking, but he won't stop
talking.
Unfortunately, we're going to probably have to move on to Connor.
I It's really unfortunate. I I almost don't want to do it. I
I'm not going to be celebrating.
I'm going to be asking why. I'm going to just be asking why a
lot of the time,
Just why.
LET'S GO!
WHO ARE CONNOR'S biggest
favorite his favorite content creators, man? Who are Connor's
favorite content creators? I appreciate that that
Uh, dude, Connor's life is falling apart and he wants to hear
my voice to console him. I'm sorry, Connor. Look away. Connor,
I'm going to have to I I have to put the sharker hat on, Connor.
Look away. Look away. I'm not going to be laughing at your pain.
I cuz it's In a real sense, uh before I even go into it, in a
real sense, it's actually very sad that that he's going to
be faced with challenges or that his family's potentially not
going to be together. Not that you can't like resolve things
or fix things. I I do think that's like
I don't like question that. I am obviously sympathetic to that,
but you also went to like MS Paint and sort of revealed the stats
of how you're becoming like a better person.
I just I just I just I just I I Okay, I've I But I do seriously
mean I might think it's funny, okay? I might think it's funny
that like some of the stuff went down this way. The overall idea
of you getting divorced is not funny to me, and I am genuinely
sorry that that's happening to you, okay? Let's go. Let's go.
Now, yes, if you have you haven't heard yet, Counter-Points went
on his live stream earlier today
and decided to tell everybody that he was getting divorced, and
he went into like excruciating detail, and I really wish he hadn't.
Not because
not even because I'm going to be hurtled, but it's like it's
just I don't know how to tell people this, but anything you reveal
in a personal sense will be used to cudgel you later in the online
sphere, especially online politics. If you're ever personal,
if you I understand why people don't like that feeling. They
don't like that that happens, right?
But, you know that it happens. Connor watches the content where
that happens. You can tell by his recommendations on YouTube
that Connor is very aware that this is how it works.
Like, he knows. He's watched me do it. And so, a little bit I'm
like, "Dude, you got to Now you got to take your medicine, okay?"
Let's just do it. All right. All right, let's just do it. So,
welcome. Welcome, everybody. >> I represented myself as
a wife guy.
And I think I am a wife guy.
Is that Is he's basically trying to say, "Since I told you guys
that this is a part of my character, I now have to update you.
I'm morally compelled to update you on my divorce." >> So,
I loved
past tense, which I know is going to scare you. Uh I loved having
a family. I love my
>> Bro, I
>> Uh I loved having a family. I love my kids actively.
I still love Mrs. Points.
what happened was in September,
we hit a rocky part of the relationship.
>> It's September of 2025.
What was happening in September of 2025?
Five.
Oh, that could go so many ways. That could go so many ways.
Can we think of anybody who reacted really inappropriately to
Charlie Kirk's assassination in a way that Connor's wife might
have been upset about? Anyway, we'll just we'll keep watching.
I don't want to spoil so we'll keep watching. >> And it's
a myriad of things. It's this
It's online politics.
It's me getting to work from home. Uh it's some of the trauma
from being in law enforcement.
>> So, Connor points says there it's live streaming, it's
online politics, it's working from home, and a little bit it's
from being a cop or whatever. Okay?
So, I do think a big part of this is
the fact
that he's had his political awakening. I'm I'm going to keep
watching, but I do think there's going to going to be some stuff
that goes on in the side chat here that I think is going to be
a little bit leading us in this direction. We'll see. We'll see
what >> some of the trauma from being in law enforcement.
It's some of the trauma from, you know, her meeting me after
uh the military.
It's the way that we were raising our kids. It's the way that
I express myself. All this kind of stuff. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Some of you guys are already guessing it.
So, uh we hit the rocks >> Some of you guys are already
guessing
Believe it or not, guys, some of you guys are already guessing
it. >> And we were on the rocks for a while.
And then, I actually did not see this
but in February, she hit me with papers,
uh sucks.
>> I hope he cuts this from the vid. Oh boy, I sure hope
Oh, you guys can't see that yet. Yeah, oh boy, I I sure hope
he cuts that from the vid.
Uh, he did not cut that from the vid. >> I wasn't happy
about it, but um, just being real from my
I left law enforcement for her because she asked me to.
in 2019, she said, "Hey, like law enforcement is messing us up.
You need to leave the job because it's destroying
>> And so, I left law enforcement for her, which was like
a very big deal to me, but there was like a lot of energy around
that incident. And I'm pretty sure if you talk to her, too, uh,
she would say that I articulated to her multiple times, like
she would acknowledge how big of a sacrifice that was,
uh, I don't feel like that actually resonated in behavior
because effectively, I took a career. I've told you guys how
difficult law enforcement was. Um, it's a job that I loved, but
didn't love me back. And I basically burned it for her.
But that wasn't enough,
um, to salvage the relationship.
>> Wait, when did he get out of Was that a long time ago?
I That's weird that it's like been like latent kind of just this
like pall hanging over the relationship for that long, cuz he's
been not a law enforcement officer for years. Yeah, 6 years.
Jesus. That's a long time. >> So, we made it, you know,
for 6 years. I would say we were together for 15 years.
Um, I I was loyal, dutiful
to one woman for 15 years, and I don't
I don't regret anything.
I got my kids, we had a lot of fun, we went on adventures together,
we did a lot of serious [__] Um she helped me through
a lot of serious [__] So, I'm actually like really
grateful to her in a lot of ways and I articulated that to her.
Um I am, if I'm being honest, I'm a
angry, caught off guard that like, "Hey, I feel like I could
have done more if I had been up to date and figured out like
where you were leaning."
That's going to be That's going to be where we go, right? She
thinks she sees a character flaw, like something that can't be
fixed, and he thinks he doesn't get a chance He didn't get a
chance to fix it. That's got to be where we go with this. >> bitter
and angry about some aspects of it because I was really ready
to like
I was I was ready to go for the next like four or five decades
and die
uh with this woman
and
she just didn't want that, you know? >> Oh my god.
Is this not just like for so long Connor has clearly
fetishized, idealized
Steven Crowder's lifestyle. Is this not his opportunity to move
away from everybody, to to move to Miami,
to put some distance between him and his
and just be the true liberal that he's always had inside of him
that could never ever That could never ever be all of these things.
Yes. Connor, you too
Yes. You too could get all these things, Connor. You could do
it.
And craziest thing of all, Connor's taller than he is.
Like I think he's got, you know, he's he's better looking guy.
He He could make it work, man. >> Uh the point is that
it wasn't a fidelity issue on my end, it wasn't a fidelity issue
on her end. Uh we actually had a pretty rich physical life in
my opinion for a very long time. It was literally since
that [__] >> Did this guy just say we [__]
a lot? We [__] a lot. Yo, we [__] all
the time. We
>> got on the uh we actually had a pretty rich physical
life, in my opinion. >> Oh, why did you add in your opinion?
I Okay, I That could mean one of two things. That could mean
I don't want to speak for her cuz I don't truly know, or it could
mean that she let you know.
You know what? I'm not going to be able to give him the benefit
of the doubt in a lot of these other cases. So, I'm going to
give him the better benefit of the doubt for this one, okay?
For this one, I got to give him the benefit of the doubt. He
means just he's not speaking for her. He thinks for He thinks
for him. You know, for him it was good. It was fulfilling. He's
not saying she let him know otherwise. I do wish I do wish you
wouldn't share any of this cuz not only like not even for me,
okay? You're just going to say he goes a lot. I could like laugh
at this guy. Haha, you think feel like you have to tell me you
[__] a lot. But the The only thing I would say here
bro, if you're If you haven't cleared like everything you're
about to say with your wife,
there's a chance she comes out and says to counter, okay, what
you're saying. You got to be real careful in situations like
this when you're talking about your intimacy like online or something.
Your wife could easily just come out and go, "No, he's lying."
And then you look bad. >> But that's okay. This is something
serious that I probably needed to tell you guys for a while.
I wanted to get through it first.
>> Oh, it's been a while. >> like, "Hey Connor, you
kind of alluded to the fact that the wife was getting a different
schedule.
You kind of alluded to the fact that things were changing,
but you didn't really tell us what was going on." It's because
I wanted to get through it first. You know, I I didn't want to
tell you guys and then like crash out. I wanted to like hold
my [__] relatively together,
get through it, and then >> You went through it. Like,
this is the opposite of what I feel like Like, I could give I
could give you leaking this if it just happened. Right? That
you want to talk about it, you feel like emotionally disregulated.
How do you get through it? Like, the thing most streamers do,
or most like really weird streamers do, is they like literally
have these crashes, they go on a stream and they talk about it
directly, and then they just keep talking about it over time.
And instead,
he's like been in this bad place
since February, I think he said. February's papers. So, 3 months
now.
He's been in this bad place. He's not been leaning on his audience
at all. And then, now, after all of that, he's like, "Hey, now
I'm through it. I feel stable. Let me tell you about some crazy
>> She was supposed to divorce me and get uglier, so I
could be like, "Ah, you know, don't need that lady. She dodged
a bullet, you know. F that broad. Blah blah blah blah blah."
She was supposed to get uglier, so I could talk [__]
about her, and she got prettier.
Which is very annoying.
Um but I also, you know, started working out and, you know, cooking
for myself >> Dude, are you serious? Dude, do not do every
divorce dad trope. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. I can't do it. I can't
do it. I can't do it. I can't do it. I think I Huh. Huh. He's
doing every single one. He's doing every single one at the same
time. Please stop. Please stop. No. >> and taking care
>> And yet, I keep going. >> of myself a little bit
better than, you know, happens in the happens when you're running
an entire family. So, like, I've
physically, as well. Um so,
you know, that's why I'm going to make an OnlyFans. But anyways,
so I >> Okay. So, if you wanted to know if he's feeling
himself with the haircut, you got your answer. He's feeling himself.
>> I did download the dating apps because basically even
though this entire process like wrapped up within the past few
weeks, like I said, I haven't I haven't been intimate with anybody
since September of last year. And
>> How did you tell? Why? Why? Why? You didn't say that
specifically. You said it was like on the rocks.
You said it was on the rocks. You didn't say it specifically.
Bro, so many conservative women when when Charlie Kirk was taken
away, they carried the flame, okay, by drying themselves out
entirely. It's I don't know. I don't know.
Dude, this is I I he's he's an open book right now and it's so
bad. I I want him to stop talking, but he won't stop >> Um
basically it women that were auto filtered for me were women
who were looking for a serious relationship. They were looking
for their husband.
And so what happened is I swiped and swiped and swiped and swiped
and swiped and swiped and swiped. And truth be told, I denied
a like I I did not swipe on a lot of people, but I swept through
all the profiles that I had gotten.
And within 2 weeks, Yeah, try Grinder. Yeah, I'll be very popular
on Grinder.
No. No.
No. Adult place. I think it's on Bumble or Hinge, I forget which
one. And especially because I put myself in as a 38-year-old,
is the basically it women that were auto filtered for me were
women who were looking for a serious relationship. They were
looking for their husband.
And so what happened is I swiped and swiped and swiped and swiped
and swiped and swiped and swiped. And truth be told, I denied
a like I I did not swipe on a lot of people, but I swept through
all the profiles that I had gotten. >> Wait, why is he
going through all of that stuff? Why is he doing it all? I thought
he I thought I could have sworn that he was like just telling
us that he wanted a serious relationship. Isn't that what you're
looking for? Is that what you said you're looking for? >> And
why, weirdly enough, I recommend Tinder over Hinge and Bumble,
is I know that it has the reputation of a hookup
but the truth is that everybody's on
And what I mean by that is like every kind of person
is on Tinder. So, there's like finest babe gold diggers who are
looking for people to take them out and spend tons of money on
them. There's super attractive chicks who are looking either
for like a hot hookup or they're looking for their husband.
Then there's medium attractive chicks who have personalities
and they show off their personalities on Tinder because like
the first picture, I swear to god I could give dating advice
based off of 2 weeks on the dating >> To be honest, Connor's
probably got more experience than a lot of guys actually giving
dating advice on the internet, so >> I'm going to describe
my current dating
before I continue.
So, since it didn't work out with the Orlando health social worker,
who was very nice and we had a great time, but I just wasn't
her guy and she might not have been my gal, so that's okay.
The I I remembered somebody who was local who, weirdly enough,
this this this is going to be like a kind of wholesome, so I
want you guys to put on your wholesome pants and I want Solidus
to stop being depressed real quick.
my first girlfriend
okay? Ever. And I I want to describe that to you real quick.
I moved from Belgium
Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude.
Dude. Okay. Why do you think your chat's depressed, Connor? This
is the most depressing stream
I've ever seen in my life.
Your audience is depressed because you are acting like you are
the worst caricature of the deadbeat dad, the divorced dad. You're
like you're like
you're like True Detective, Woody Harrelson, eating the TV dinner
right now. Oh, I'm looking to cook. I'm I'm getting into cooking
on my own. I'm cooking for myself and I'm on the dating apps
and I'm focusing on work. Bro. Bro. Stop. YOU GOT TO STOP, MAN.
You got to stop. Stop.
>> So, there was this girl that when I was 15, okay, literally
15. Okay. We uh went out on a couple of dates, but we were 15,
so we didn't do anything. We probably kissed like two or three
times. We went to this place um Orlando people might literally
remember it, but there was this place called Rock Haven.
Okay. And Rock Haven is a place where like teenagers go to booty
dance to music that's way too loud. And we went there when we
were like 14 or 15 and we booty danced and I was like, this is
way too vulgar for my conservative Christian
But we had a good time.
>> Bunch of bunch of Okay, I can't I can't comment because
of the ages, okay? I don't know what to say about the ages. Connor's
first experience with um first like just hovering somewhat close
to his experiences as a teenager was like, uh, this is really
off-putting. Uh.
>> We had a good time. And so we had a good time, but I
didn't have a car.
And so my parents were driving
Yeah, my my parents were driving me
uh to her house. First you're married and now you are divorced.
That one guy was right, you're so inconsistent.
Okay, I hope that's a reference. So anyways, so my parents were
driving me over to her house to take her out on a date. And what
ended up happening was
I was embarrassed that my parents kept having to drive me. And
she lived like 20 minutes away. So, since I was so embarrassed
of having to being driven to her house, I was like, "Hey, I don't
think this is going to work." But what's funny about that is
I got her earrings for
And she still has the earrings.
Which is hilarious cuz like 20 years later, she still has the
earrings.
uh anyways, so I realized that she was
And I DM'd her and I was like, "Hey, I know this is like a shot
in the dark. We haven't talked in like 20 years. Uh are you still
with your husband? Because she
uh was married. And like I I knew that she was married. Her husband
actually went to my high school. Um
But like I'd seen her at the grocery store and I thought she
was cute.
>> Oh, while you were married or When When did this happen,
Carter? Wait.
This is so weird.
>> And so I DM'd her and I was like, "Hey, you know, are
you still married? Whatever. Blah blah blah blah blah." Total
shot in the dark. It like are you still local? Are you still
married?
And she was like, "No.
I got divorced about 6 years ago. >> Oh god. >> my
kids. We're still raising our kids together. We're still split,
etc. etc. But I'm local.
um so basically, I was like, "Okay, are you single?" And there
was like a little dance around that where like she was trying
to I think she was trying to figure out if I was trying to cheat
on my wife or not. Because like all my social media was still
like, you know, pictures of the family and picture of me and
the wife and picture of this. And I'm not going to delete any
of those pictures. That's a part of me. That's a part
part of my life. That's a part of my
And so, um you know, she was trying to figure out if I was trying
to cheat on my wife and I was like, "No, no, no. You know, wife
and I split. Um you know, we're going through it, but you know,
we're getting through the end process and blah blah blah blah
blah. And so, I would like to I would like to take you out on
a date. And so she said yes.
And she is pretty.
I like her face.
I like other aspects of her. I'm not trying to >> It's
such a [__] cave, man, dude. >> She is pretty.
I like her face.
She is pretty. I like her face. Are you single? I want to go
on date. Me like your face. It's nice.
>> want to be vulgar, but I but I do like other aspects
of her and I've expressed those things to her. She's very nice.
And she uh also does a very noble
Good stuff. She works with and I joked about this multiple times.
She works with severely
>> OH, THAT'S WHY THE APPROACH WORKS. She finds it endearing.
Okay. >> She's a behavioral specialist in the local school
system. And so her job is to work with like severely kids. And
I'm not talking about like you. I'm not talking about my chat.
I'm talking about like kids who like piss themselves, [__]
themselves, don't have the ability to communicate, don't have
the ability to sit, throw tantrums, throw things, fling things,
and all that kind of stuff. And she works with them every single
day. And so her days are kind of rough, but she loves it.
And not only does she love it, but she has a very like noble
spirit about this and I'm I'm going to I'm going to tell you
like a story. Yeah, the the joke I I >> You're already
telling us a story, man. We're going to be going to meta. We
go meta. We going to level two. We need to go to a dream within
a dream. >> We'll say the joke eventually, okay? >> You
guys have no idea. If you think time slows down when we enter
one of Connor's stories, wait until you enter a story within
a story, okay? >> As a matter of fact, I'll say it. >> Her
her dealing with severely people every single day is like going
to be a boon
to our relationship.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> She She literally deals with
severely kids every single day, so my level of >> Do you
want to know how I made this bolter gun? Do you want to know
I made it's like from Warhammer 40K. I made a bolter gun. Do
you know what a bolter gun is? Do you know what the
Do you know what the Horus Heresy is? Do you want to know about
these things? >> Autism is fine.
It's perfect, you know? I have the fun autism. She works with
people all day. Perfect match.
So, anyways, everybody in chat gets it. Yeah, yeah. So, so so
so so so so. Um basically that's my deep admiration. And so,
we were going over tattoos. We you know, we got some food. We
got some sandwiches. We got some tea. We were hanging out. We
were yapping. And then I'm kind of taking this as a sign from
God, you know, that that this is just who I'm supposed to talk
to and who I'm supposed to date at this point in my life. So,
she has a tattoo of a starfish on her wrist. Okay?
And she says, "Have you ever heard the story of the starfish?"
And I was like, "Hold on." Because this is one of my
SP, SP, I'm going to have to ban you. I'm going to have to ban
you. I'm going to have to ban you right now.
You said we need to go deeper. We need to go one story deeper.
This is now a story within a story within a story. We are here.
We are here, and it's your fault. WHY DID YOU MANIFEST THIS?
NO. NO.
>> ONE OF MY TWO favorite >> Have you ever heard
the story of the
>> parables ever. I I think I told you guys this multiple
multiple multiple times. And I was like, I >> He's telling
us the story of the starfish within the story of his him
connecting and dating his first ever girlfriend within the story
of his divorce.
I can't. >> I'm going to describe the parable of the starship
or the starfish, excuse me. And if you say it if you say that
this is the parable, like that's going to blow my mind off. Like
like I'm just going to have my entire mind blown. So, obviously
I told you guys this before. Um my
the shorter story is the uh the German st- saying of even if
the world were to end tomorrow, I would plant an apple tree today,
which I think is amazing. It It captures the cynicism of the
Germans, but it also captures the optimism of doing the right
thing even if everything's falling apart. That's one of my favorite
sayings. My other favorite saying, which I've told you guys multiple
times over the past year, is it's a parable. So, there's a young
man on a beach, there's a thousand washed up starfish, he picks
up a starfish, he throws it into the ocean, and then he picks
up another one, throws it in the ocean, picks up another one,
throws it in the ocean, and then an old man walks by and he says,
"There's a thousand of them. You're not going to get to all of
them. Um you're you're wasting your time. What What you're doing
doesn't matter." And then the young man, undeterred, picks up
another starfish and throws it in the ocean and he says, "It
mattered to that one." And so, it's the statement of our orientation
within existence that we can look at the overwhelming nature
of the world's problems and say ultimately that we as individuals
don't have an impact and therefore you can become a nihilist
hedonist or a cynic and not try to have a positive impact in
the >> Uh I hate this guy, but I'm not cynical. Sorry.
Sorry, I was reading a chat message. I should pop that up. I
hate this guy. I'm not cynical, so I don't hate this story. It's
just like not It's not the time, Matt. >> Whereas, you
know, the young boy, the person that we should idolize, is saying
will it matter to that one? Okay. And so, she's like, "Yes.
That's the story." And so, at that point I'm just like, I don't
even give a about anything else. That's such like a positive
orientation
of the way that >> Do you want to get married? Hey, you
know the story of the starfish? Do you want to get married? I
Will you make me the happiest man for the second time? >> Best
advice for me, take everything slow. This is a new stage, don't
rush anything, get grounded and secure, and don't bite off more
than you can chew. I'm going slow-ish.
I'm going slow-ish.
And uh I guess we should get into the family dynamic real quick.
just being real, uh we could have done 50/50 uh with the kids
and with the house and called it a day, but Victoria wanted um
more substantive custodial relationship with the kids, and I
wasn't necessarily opposed to that. She's been there >> Oh,
no. Oh, no. Oh. >> Well, I didn't concede very much, but
I conceded a little bit for the sake of amicability um and and
her desires. So, what happened was just being very straightforward,
it's 60/40. Could have been 50/50, but it's 60/40. So, I have
my kid >> 60/40 is really not that tangible, >> One
week I have them 2 days a week, and then I have like visitation
that I can do. Um and then I have them another week 3 days a
week. So, out of a 14-day period, I think I have them eight or
nine days. Um you know, once you add in like the I can visit
them at any time kind of
>> Really, this one is where I'm like, "Dude, not appropriate."
I I
Don't talk about your kids on the internet. Don't You should
just have a red line. Don't talk about your kids on the internet.
You should just I understand why you want to. I understand you're
proud of your kids. You never understand what how the things
you say could be used later. You cannot calculate out. Do not
ever talk about your kids on the internet. It's always a mistake.
I understand that you want to like share with your chat. You
feel like they're an important part of your life.
Do that in a maybe do that elsewhere. Don't do it on a live stream
on YouTube. >> So, I asked my oldest because this process
has been unfolding for the past 2 months. >> I asked my
oldest, I was like, "Hey, how would you rate your life on a 1
to 10?" And he's like, "Nine." And I was like, >> I asked
my child, "How do you rate your life on a scale of 1 to 10?"
>> Bro, what the [__] are you saying on your
live stream right now? Oh, his oldest can't be that old.
His kid His kid can't be that old, man. >> past 2 months.
I asked my oldest, I was like, "Hey, how would you rate your
life on a 1 to 10?" And he's like, "Nine." And I was like, "Damn,
that's pretty [__] good." Okay, all things considered,
he is upset. He is upset. He's expressed how upset he is about
this process. But he still is rating his life at a at a nine
out of 10. So, I'm like, "Okay, that's good." Then, um >> He
really is becoming a liberal at heart, isn't he? He really is
becoming a liberal at heart.
I need
I'm really upset that you're You guys aren't going to be here.
Like,
oh, I I'm so [__] Please, Connor, skip this if you're
listening.
I can't believe you guys are getting
Yeah, but I can't say he's battered up without empirical without
empirical evidence. So, could you just on a scale of 1 to 10,
how's your life? >> With Tinder, this is this is the way
that I understand it, okay? Bear in mind I'm I I'm bringing two
weeks of dating advice to you. But this was the vibe that I got
and this is how I think it works. So, on Tinder >> you're
going to set a geographic zone of 100 miles. And you're going
to set your age bracket at like 19 or 20 to 40, okay? I don't
know how old you are. If you're in your late 20s, set it to 32
or 35. Set it to the max amount of age because there are actually
some really attractive 40-year-olds out there. Set it to the
maximum age that you would be willing to date casually or seriously,
you know? And then, basically just swipe. Okay, and I'm not kidding.
There are This is going to be very rude and if you are an overweight
six and or a trans girl, please know that I still love you as
I say this, okay? There are a lot of overweight sixes and a lot
of trans girls. Like I'm really I'm really not trying to be mean,
but I swear to god out of 100 people on uh Tinder, there might
be >> I do feel like Connor's the kind of guy who like
Connor's the kind of guy who can't clock a trans woman
and he ends up like going downstairs on like an eighth date and
he still hasn't clocked it even after they've gone on dates at
a I feel like Connor's that guy. Connor's that guy, okay?
Yeah, we should continue with the video. >> that I would
actually want to date and there there are some pretty trans girls
out there, too. Um but, you know, I I don't want my future girlfriend
have a Sorry, it's just something about me. Not not a huge fan
of my future girlfriend have a
So, so pay attention. Pay attention. There's some passwords out
there. Um and so you're just going to swipe. And of course like
the one through 10 scale is going to be contextual to you. I
think I showed you guys like a map of the way that I think you
should evaluate a person. Like what it I don't know if I'll pull
it up. I'll pull it up. Where did I put it? And I personally
drew this map because I knew that I was going to be on the dating
market soon, you know? And and I knew that I was going to be
evaluating my partners
based on this criteria. >> Oh boy. >> And so, hold
on. Let me let me share this real quick.
if if I actually had to rate myself, okay? Let let me go ahead
and rate >> Please. Please do.
Oh no. Dude, we're we're about to get the fresh and fit, okay?
Rachel, what do you rate yourself scale of 1 to 10? What do you
rate yourself on a scale of 1 to 10, man. >> I'm going
to say I'm a solid
solid seven. And on a
good day, I'm an eight for physical.
I'm a three. On a good >> That's uh that's a little rough.
That's a little rough. That's a little rough. >> good day,
I'm a six. But, I'm working >> Okay, this is this is the
other this is the next one. This next one I feel like we're not
in the greatest spot, but we're going to cope about it. >> a
job that I love, and if I figure it out, I could be an eight
or 10 on the
Now, emotional stability,
I'm a five,
maybe a four, but I'm a self-
>> I'm sorry, a four is like about what I expected. I expected
around a four on this one.
four or five. And I think self-awareness does a lot for like
emotional stability. Like if you're >> Only in tricking
people.
Only in tricking people, man. I'm a I'm like aware of all the
things that [__] me up.
Yeah, that's doesn't help. What are you doing about it? What
are you doing about it, Connor? You're aware of all the things
that [__] you up. What have you done to fix it?
Cuz I'll be honest, man, unless you got something getting done
to fix it. Holy sh- And I say this as somebody who's doing nothing
to fix it, okay? I'm I'm I'm also an aware person, which means
I'm aware of you and what you're saying right now, that you're
[__] up and you you know it, and you're not really
doing very much.
You're a [__] mess. >> It is what it is. Like
in in a in self-awareness can obviously like increase your emotional
stability bracket, in my opinion. And then spiritual beauty,
I'm probably it really depends on what you're into, right?
>> If you like somebody who's like abrasive and fun and
adventurous and weird and likes to deal with that [__]
and all that kind of stuff, I could be the most spiritually beautiful
person you ever met. I might be like an eight out of 10. Like
I might be a nine out of 10 on spiritual beauty. But if you don't
like vulgarity, if you don't like looking at the horrors of life,
if you don't like looking at violence, if you don't like looking
at politics, if you don't like looking at, you know, if you don't
like being verbally abrasive, then I'm probably like a two, you
know? It actually straight up depends. In the spiritual realm,
like your soul, who you are, and what you're about, it actually
really depends on what you're into. There's a lot of chicks that
live in the building I work at that are crushing on me, but like
I work Dude, that Jonah No, no, no, Jonah, I'm sorry. I hate
to >> Dude, everybody Everybody dates through the job.
I'm sorry. That's just like where you meet people. I'm sorry.
It's just where you meet people, especially if it's a job with
like younger people, people who are working close proximity.
That's where people do it. I know that you feel like it's a hack,
but unfortunately, you're going to know those people better than
you know anyone else. Sorry.
Sorry. You have to have boundaries. You You need to exert boundaries,
right? You need to actually be able to to draw red lines and
say, "This is where we fix things or this where we cut it off
if it doesn't work."
I'm just telling you, that's where people do it. >> Ooh,
get up your [__] Dude, every single person I dated
was somebody that I met through work or school. So, first first
girlfriend who I'm dating right now, school. >> Oh, the
voice cracks are killing me, man. The voice cracks are killing
me, >> Second girlfriend, school. Third girlfriend, school.
Uh, fourth girlfriend, military. Then fifth girlfriend, school.
Sixth girlfriend, school and work. You have to [__]
where you eat, bro. If there's a good-looking girl who is actually
crushing on you, and she's like cool, interesting, smart, ambitious,
etc. >> Now I'm a little hesitant on my advice. Now I'm
a little hesitant on my voice advice, but I do think that's broadly
true. I'm sorry.
If you like your social circles are where most people date. That's
like what That's how you met people before dating apps, man.
>> If there's a girl who gives you googly eyes, like so
for instance, back when I worked at Nordstrom, I still remember
this girl's name, too. There was a girl named Suzy Vella, okay?
She She worked at the hot tax one, and she used to come >> uh,
every week, basically, for like 3 months in order to buy shoes
from me, because she was a Vince Camuto addict. And like we would
talk about shoes, we would talk about fashion, we would talk
about life, we would talk about this, talk about that. The only
reason I didn't ask her out was because I had a girlfriend. But
I 100% would have asked out Suzy Vella if I wasn't dating someone.
And then, um, what's the other thing? There was a girl who used
to work at So, Nordstrom had a coffee bar and there was There
was a girl there who was like younger than me. I was probably
mid-late 20s. I was probably mid-20s. And she was like 19 or
20. And she would kind of always like hand me my food with like
the extra, you know, 3 seconds of eye contact. And dude, if I
wasn't If I didn't have a girlfriend, I 100% would have asked
that chick out. Are you kidding me? >> This is This is
bleak.
He's like running through all of his missed opportunities earlier
in life. It's Woo.
>> That, dude. You have If there is a girl that you like
at your work who is cute and you guys socially compatible, you
have to ask her out. Do not waste that
Connor needs to either stop covering Hasan or bitter or sweepers
until you start picking fights with them online. You got to branch
out from all the other Hasan haters. Sure. Nothing ages you more
than a crowd of 20-somethings. True. Early 20s girl def isn't
in the mood. Well, dude, if you're in your mid to late 20s or
early 30s, a young 20s girl is in the cards. You know why? Because
you're young as Because you're dumb as No offense. I'm the same
guy that I was when I was 20
>> You're the same guy you were when you were 32, bruh.
>> 5. But I have so much more experience that makes me
more salty, dude. You You have to understand like even if you're
25 or even if you're 29, you're still young, man. You are going
to do so much growing in the next decade. You have to just be
young. Just enjoy being young, dude. Just be cringe. Just be
cringe, man. Ask her out. She >> This is Dude, I >> Uh
all you can hear All I hear is like regret that he's in a relationship
for so long. I'm sorry. It's all I can hear the whole time. It's
just like regret that he did this and it didn't work out. And
it's tr- It's It's tough. It's tough to listen through, man.
>> says, "Ew." Okay. Keep it >> Like oh, you I I
didn't get enough of I didn't get a chance. I didn't get, you
know, I I was just in this whole thing and then she walked out
and I didn't take any risks. I didn't do anything cuz I was in
a relationship.
That's all I hear is take risks, do
>> Uh back when I was back when I was dating my Orlando
health social worker or whatever because I wanted to date a nurse.
I'm dating a teacher, which is great. So, I'm not complaining
at all, but I wanted to date a nurse. And I literally Googled
>> There is some trauma there. That's That's the most traumatized
thing I've ever heard in my entire life. I actually just wanted
to date a nurse really badly.
>> Dude, where do the nurses drink after shift in Orlando?
And there's a specific >> Bro, what the
I've never heard anything like this before. He has like this
whole theory about how if you are willing to take care of people,
you're a good person who's like aligned values with him. So,
maybe that's why he's thinking nurse. But, I
Bro, I'm so No, no, no, no, no, it's not a fetish thing. It's
not a fetish thing. He just doesn't understand that like That
could be true of nurse students, but like 95% of nurses
totally jaded by their job in a way that they're not going to
have similar values. I promise you. Like so insanely You think
you're jaded as like a former Marine? As like a grunt? You shot
a couple people? Wait until you're a nurse, man. Just wait. >> specific
bar. So, if I hadn't bumped into my girlfriend, and if the social
worker and I had broken up, I was literally going to go to the
bar where the nurses drink after work, and I was just going to
hang out there and see if, you know, I vibed with somebody. And
then same thing with uh the teachers. If you're like, "Damn,
I want to date a teacher, not a student, a teacher." I would
literally Google, "Where do the professors from X college go
out to drink? Where do the teachers from this school go out to
drink?" Because sometimes they'll be like a forum post or a Facebook
post or something like that where it's like, "You know, we have
half off education industry night on Thursdays. Special shout-out
to Eagle's Nest High School for dropping by." And there'll be
like a picture
>> I don't know if this is weird or not. It's certainly
weird to share it. I feel like it's just odd to share it, to
be honest with you. Like if you do it, just keep it to yourself
and don't tell the people that you're doing it.